we're gonna go down to Russia and a
bizarre and threatening speech from
President Vladimir Putin he was speaking
outside of Moscow where he focused on a
number of issues frequently highlighted
by the right wing here in America but as
Holly Williams reports none of that
rhetoric can hide the fact that there is
a desperate struggle for his own Army to
make any Headway at all in the war that
he started in Ukraine
the West is playing a dangerous bloody
and dirty game said Vladimir Putin
sounding like a leader from the Soviet
past
he cast Russia as the victim of
so-called Western Elites and even railed
against gay pride parades
but around 500 miles from Moscow
it's Putin's invading Army that's
inflicting deadly chaos after months of
embarrassing setbacks for the Russian
military their focus appears to be the
small city of bakmut with little
strategic significance the ukrainians
are dug in and determined to hold them
off
you won't get Ukraine they write on
these mortars before firing them at the
Russians a new wave of Russian
airstrikes has succeeded in damaging
Ukraine's power grid ukrainians are
trying to cut back on electricity use
including the President Vladimir
zielinsky
a hard winter will not scare us he said
we know the darkest night becomes the
dawn for CBS morning's Holly Williams
Kiev Ukraine